il fait beau il fait presque chaud les
promeneurs sont de sortie et
malheureusement les tic aussi françois
michaud faire se demande
il existe un vaccin pour les chiens
pourquoi ne pas en avoir développé un
pour les humains je pense que mon chien
est vacciné contre la maladie cela il
est mieux protégé que c'est le chef du
service des maladies infectieuses de
l'hôpital général juif qui le type la
raison pour laquelle il existe un vaccin
pour les chiens mais pas pour l'homme
c'est que il a existé un vaccin pour
l'homme mais on a trouvé que son
efficacité était très faible
le line rixe a effectivement été vendu
2,98 à 2002 il était efficace
environ 75% par comparaison le vaccin
contre la rougeole c'est 95% la médecine
c'est toujours comme ça il faut que les
bénéfices n'ont pas nettement sur les
inconvénients
donc si vous devez vacciner des gens et
vous avez des gens qui ont des douleurs
au point d'une opération qui ont des
douleurs un peu musculaire et qui en
bout de ligne pas beaucoup d'efficacité
le bénéfice de faire une campagne de
vaccination n'est pas traité et donc ce
qu'il n'est pas bon pour l'humain serait
bon pour pitou
on a demandé au docteur qui reviennent
caisses d'armes reste de l'ordre des
médecins ses liens avec ce qui existe
mais c'est pas le mode de prévention qui
est on trouve plus efficace et plus 5
d'âgés avec des médicaments qui empêche
de transmettre la maladie de lyme
mais les pharmaceutiques continuent de
chercher une nouvelle formule pour l'os
à une compagnie qui trouve un vaccin
demain avec tes joues garantie qu il
vendrait à 200 dollars et des gens
d'acheter en masse on parle d'environ
300 cas par année au québec
trente mille aux états unis